the toys to life genre is huge and while
the Skylanders team gets to make up
whatever creatures they want the Disney
infinity devs have to dig into the
Disney catalog for inspiration now
there's no shortage of movies to pick
from which begs the question what's
coming to disney infinity in 2016 thanks
to the team's most recent live stream
now we know Nick and Judy from Zootopia
are out now and velu from the jungle
book will be available this spring on
the marble side we're getting Black
Panther ant-man and a new civil war
inspired Captain America Marvel
battlegrounds playsets are coming too
that's all scheduled for this spring
additional Marvel characters are planned
for this year plus new figures from the
Star Wars and Pixar universes all in all
there's no shortage of new stuff headed
to disney infinity disney has plenty of
movies every year but it's nice to see
the infinity team digging deeper than
just the newest releases you can read
even more info at the Disney Interactive
blog and you can get all the Disney
infinity news you need a gamespot
fingers crossed for some Black Cauldron
characters
you